they send nevada national guard troops
to the border no
there's a finite amount of money i was
actually a
military officer in the nevada national
guard there's a finite amount of money
associated with the deployment of your
local state guard
and if you deploy them to the border
that money would dry up quickly and it
would be prevent them from responding to
any crisis associated within the borders
of our state
what we need to do is force the hand of
the federal government obviously
immigration is a federal issue
we need to support within the state the
removal of individuals who have
committed crimes
and
present them to ice accordingly
i support
legal immigration i do not support
illegal immigration and i am the only
one standing up here at this podium that
has removed anybody who has committed
crimes associated with and being
undocumented illegal within the state of
nevada thank you mr lombardo mr gilbert
same question to you would you deploy
troops to the southern border absolutely
without a doubt i would deploy the
troops but unfortunately sheriff
lombardo you know we refer to him among
us as sanctuary joe for a reason
department of justice inspector
general's report 2016 had clark county
is one of the worst
sanctuary counties in the nation on may
31 2016 it was labeled one of ten
jurisdictions that was found in
violation of federal law for not turning
over illegal immigrants to ice now
nevada has the highest illegal immigrant
population per capita in the nation 223
000 we all know it's much higher than
that that's a direct you know effect
from not enforcing the law and that took
place right here since 2014 things have
just been out of control with regards to
sanctuary city it's exploded the crime
rate by 500 percent so we have to do
something if we don't send you know help
down to the border it's going to
continue to affect us in a negative way
we can't sustain it what's going on here
right now so we absolutely must do
something and i would send our guard
down there thank you mr gilbert um mr
lombardo you were invoked there for a
minute uh 30 seconds to reply is nevada
is las vegas a sanctuary city no
sanctuary's determination comes out of
the state legislature and our
legislature has not identified or
labeled any jurisdiction within the
state of nevada's sanctuary
the removal of undocumented felonious
immigrants is done within the local
sheriff's jurisdiction and ability and
within southern nevada i do that on a
regular basis more so than any other
county in the state of nevada and it's
incumbent upon the resources available
via ice
and their ability to take those
individuals into custody and remove them
and the 500 percent
that is a fictitious number that mr
gilbert presented thank you mr lombardo
mr heller uh you have 60 seconds to
answer the full question would you send
nevada national guard troops to the
board i would but let's let's be clear
joe's not telling the truth here
what happened when he made
southern nevada a sanctuary city if you
want to live in a dangerous neighborhood
live in a sanctuary city and that's what
this guy costs you don't have to have
the legislature deem us a sanctuary city
what you do is you have a sheriff like
this guy that kicks ice out of metro
and not only does he do that he
practices catch and release
and those illegal immigrants that
committed crimes he's putting back on
the street this is the problem that we
have here in southern nevada this guy
needs to tell the truth and actually own
up to it we have a 50 increase in
homicides we have a 45 percent increase
in violent crimes here in clark county
all because of this guy deciding that he
wanted southern nevada to be a sanctuary
city and this has to stop because it's
affecting everywhere else in the state
northern nevada washoe elko winnemucca
elko now has drugs and gangs because
this guy is bringing these illegal
immigrants into this state and spreading
them across the state thank you mr
heller uh again mr lombardo you've been
uh attacked uh the the crime statistics
are they related to
the immigration issue absolutely not you
can't draw a line to the immigration
issue at all in the crime statistics and
as far as the homicide rate we are down
currently down three percent in totality
and homicide if you look at the joining
jurisdictions north las vegas and
henderson you can't say that and i have
not kicked ice out of our jail in our
system we present individuals from the
jail to ice
ice makes the determination whether they
take them what we did do is we got sued
by the aclu we lost the use of the
federal database to identify these
individuals and as a result we email
them and we make phone calls there is no
change in the procedure the national
pitcher has
lack and the resources associated for
removal
thank you thank you mr water we'll we'll
have more time later in the debate but
our next question is denise
now and then we'll come back during your
closing remarks you can go ahead and
come back dr general's reports available
on my website gilbert all right mr
gilbert thank you so now moving on to
each candidate's